turning overseas to ukraine this morning
russian forces are attacking the steel
plant sheltering some of the last
holdouts in the key southern seaport of
mariupol while some civilians have
escaped from that plant many ukrainians
near front lines are still caught up in
the fighting our charlie dagetta is
there in eastern ukraine
the ukrainian government accused russian
forces of targeting the steel plant even
as civilians try to flee from a
suffocating two months beneath it
busloads of families finally arrive to
the relative safety of ukrainian held
territory forcing residents to flee or
face death is part of a russian campaign
of terror
piece by piece the russians are tearing
apart communities hitting restaurants
and cafes shops apartment buildings
whether it's targeted or random the
effect is just the same
the population of the frontline town of
licitchansk used to be around a hundred
thousand before russian forces began a
relentless bombardment here they're now
less than three miles away and only a
handful of residents remain can you
describe what it's been like here for
the past few days
it's like a living hell elena said we
have no water there's shelling every day
desperate residents collect water from a
crater caused when an air strike hit the
base of an apartment block even as
people were taking shelter in the
basement lewd milla is not only used to
the sound of constant explosions
i'm an old woman
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta enlist
eastern ukraine